just weeks after hundreds of Rohan NGO
refugees who had been stranded at sea
were rescued off the coast of southern
Bangladesh another boat this one
carrying around 50 people was allowed
ashore on Saturday the row henkaa seen
in this video shown by a local news
outlet are believed to have been on one
of two fishing trawlers that have been
adrift at sea for months
this was after their families had to pay
ransom money to traffickers on a bigger
boat and that bigger boat is still
potentially off the coast of coughs
Bazar and these traffickers are still
holding potentially hundreds of people
on this boat until they can pay ransom
money to allow them to go to shore a
spokesman for Bangladesh is Coast Guard
denies there are currently any boats
full of our refugees in areas they
Patrol
according to government officials 29 of
the new arrivals were taken to Bosson
char a remote island in the Bay of
Bengal where it had previously been
planned to house up to a hundred
thousand Rohan NGO refugees Human Rights
Watch calls it a dangerously flood prone
island without adequate health care the
government of Bangladesh is claiming
that they've been sent there for
quarantine because they don't want to
so-called contaminate the refugee camps
in Cox's Bazar but the reality is that
the UNHCR and other aid agencies already
have quarantine facilities set up before
and and they've already processed more
than 400 people from a previous boat so
this is a excuse by the Bangladesh
government to operationalize the island
a bus on charr which they wanted to do
for quite some time in mid-april
bangladesh rescued 396 from hunger
refugees from a vessel adrift for almost
two months after failing to reach
Malaysia dozens on that boat died
survivors spoke with the Reuters news
agency about the abuses and deprivation
stay endured Milan
the traffic is riped woman and some of
them got pregnant on the boat three of
the woman's survivors are in this camp
five hundred and ten in total on the
boat including kids we ran out of food
within five days after we sailed off
rights groups are now urging the
Bangladeshi government to allow around
500 more ohanga
currently stuck on the two trawlers in
the Bay of Bengal to also come ashore
those boats have been adrift since
Malaysia rejected their arrival because
of coronavirus restrictions the
Bangladeshi Foreign Minister said last
week that those refugees are Malaysia's
responsibility to look after Mohammed
Jim Jim at Jazeera